please join me in welcoming the man who
I've worked with the year I mean the man
I got shot up with like seven hundred
bullets in Street Kings with this man
please welcome director David Ayer back
to Hall H it's ba homey
[Applause]
Mara is what's up what's up this is the
house that flick this is Netflix right
now we're here to represent Netflix
what's up
what there's how [ __ ]
[Applause]
okay oh boy I think I went over I think
I think I won't be bad but now please
welcome the producers Eric Newman and
Bryan uncle Ness a man you are not going
to believe this lady this woman can kick
some serious ass please welcome know me
repay a 12 now in bright he is a federal
agent on a mission
please welcome Hector Ramirez an amazing
young actress who holds her own against
will and Joel in the film
please welcome Lucy fries watch out Andy
Serkis this actor completely disappears
into his role the brilliant Joe as
you're 10
[Applause]
and please give it up for my man the
biggest movie star in the world
[Applause]
okay Terry heard you playing I don't do
me don't sue me please Dave are you and
I go back literally training day harsh
times Street King nobody does
West Coast grit like Dave yeah that's
real yeah please tell us about the
storyline too bright you know it's it's
about La it's about a really [ __ ] up
LA but our world [ __ ] up you know and
that's what's pretty cool about this
movies I get to explore some real
interesting social issues you know this
is the world where orcs and elves and
fairies are real you know and magic is
real and what happens if we take it
seriously and this isn't like some
[ __ ] pg-13 standard-issue studio
movie I mean this is like I was able to
do my [ __ ] here right I was able to
really tell a [ __ ] story okay I was
able to like do my thing and and these
actors with me I mean they absolutely
killed it you know so you haven't seen
with this before this is a new kind of
thing we're doing yeah Wow let's talk
about your reteam with your Suicide
Squad homey Will Smith yeah tell us
about your character yeah right yeah I
play the detective ward you know and
it's it was like such a beautiful thing
to be able to get back with Dave and
especially in this opportunity it is
such a bizarre world I mean I'm sure you
can tell a little bit from the trailer
but it's this crazy mashup of like the
grit and the the that hard rated-r grime
of you know training day like that kind
of vibe but then smashed with Lord of
the Rings it's like it's this really
spectacular world and you know at the
center of the story
is you know my character war with Joel's
character and Joel plays an orc and his
character is the first orc on the LAPD
so it just felt really great you know to
be an african-american police officer
that just found you know somebody else
to be racist again never get to be on
that side of racism when you're black
they look man I want to works in my car
but now it's great to have this size of
a spectacular world but then to really
narrow the story down to something
really simple and human as a foolish
prejudice you know it was it was it was
really beautiful
now Joel give it up I'll go I am a major
fan of you I mean from warrior to loving
I mean you have this a bit yeah yeah he
has this tremendous ability to just
really encapsulate a character please
tell us about your character here in
Bryan well the great thing about
transforming for this characters when
someone puts a couch on your face yeah
which is what I called my makeup because
it might have fun it's impossible not to
transform I read the script and I was so
in love with a character who you know I
love Lord of the Rings the idea of
playing a torque who is trying
desperately to be as much like a human
being as possible I could serve it is a
human being who almost does not
understand irony wit or any kind of
humor which will brings in spades and I
think it brings these speeds it's racist
in Spain
that's reference that's racist it's
everywhere it sneaks up on us everywhere
so we have a deep deep clack and pull
that the idea that I I'm playing a guy
who just really wants to be liked and
yet it looks like a monster I got to
tell you though driving around downtown
LA in a car with the windows open and no
lockdown streets and I'm looking like I
look in the movie the power of Will
Smith nobody cares that a monster was
driving apart I feel like well like who
cares a chauffeur is a monster LA don't
give a day now no me upset you scared me
you scared me
in this era first of all I have never
seen a bad ass female villain like this
you have never seen anything like this
in your life yeah you are not ready I'm
trying to tell you I'm very scared right
now go what was your preparation like
what was that um well I did a lot of
fight training I was David always once
his actor to come in and do like a long
like preparation period so I did a lot
of fight training a lot of shooting I
was out in the shooting range it's like
big on small Dawn's and then I was and I
had to try to learn how to move in
really high heels and a tight suit
gloves rings jewelry it was a lot and
then contact lenses elf ears teeth it
was like everything that makes it really
hard but but on the day it was amazing
how I just I I loved I loved my
character and she seems to be evil and
quite brutal but from my perspective she
was doing she was fighting for a better
world like she's trying to create
something beautiful but her method is
quite vicious sometimes but um I I love
there she was um and the elves are the
best-dressed I we are invented above I
like the peak it's like this world you
know it's a little bit about the
divisions in life you know but in this
case you know the elves are like the
one-percenters they run the world they
dress very nice they get all the dealer
samples the the humans
kind of in the middle middle management
and then and then the orcs or the
workers are the guys that dig ditches
and build your houses and build your
roads you know but you don't really get
any respect and they get their ass
kicked by the cops all the time so oh
yeah no it's a really beautiful
hierarchy like that in the film and you
know David did a really great job and
max landis adir the original screenplay
also it is is such a beautiful snapshot
of our world
you know without without hammering on it
too much and you just see all of the
layers and the people and all the
different issues and at the end of the
day everybody's really just trying to
have a good life you know but then it
turns into bright you will never look at
the Keebler Elf saying well ml can get
you the Melville yeah not Eric and Bryan
how do you create an incredible world
that you built here in Bryan we spent a
lot of money I look at that and I start
to sort of sweat um in reality we
beginning with a great script from max
landis and David's outstanding
leadership every artist on the film in
front of and behind the camera really
cared about this movie in the world and
they understood it and we went very deep
in it talking about how this happened
and the different races and how they've
gotten along and how they haven't gotten
along and you know it really is about
that level of commitment that across the
board and we just took it incredibly
seriously and you know working with
David makes it a lot easier he's so
authentic and especially shooting in LA
I mean there was David is really good at
finding disgusting locations yeah we
were a lot of alleys with a lot of
cockroaches and rats that really helps
yeah
actually actually you guys right the
monitor we were in a cockroach crew
that's true I remembered a little
different we had a different experience
that isn't true
you know Comic Con is really for most of
us the
one of the very few times we actually
get to do our jobs in California so to
be able to shoot a film and to take
advantage of the California subsidies
and sure you can't you cannot shoot Los
Angeles in Atlanta you can't do it so
but it's actually great you know it has
a lot to do with I think how Netflix
does their business is you know they let
you be a filmmaker and they're like
what's the best place to shoot this
movie and I'm like Los Angeles fine
we're going to do it on it gave me all
the tools they gave me all the resources
they let me be creative you know you can
ask the actors the environment on set it
was like an independent movie it felt
like I was making you know my first film
harsh times or something it was it was
just a lot of love on set and a lot of
support a lot of support from Netflix
and they really let me have my voice and
they gave the actors space and they gave
us space to make something really
incredible and that may not quite land
with you guys you have to understand
what the opposite is and sort of what
the real situation is out there with a
lot of filmmakers and I think Netflix is
going to pull a lot more talent because
they are so supportive they are
supportive of the process it feels like
it's 20 years ago with them it's kind of
amazing it's like well one day I came to
set I've been rehearsing this long fight
sequence first day on in this location
amazing location smelled quite bad
though but it was amazing and then David
is like okay I want to come running over
this like strip is like a strip stage
right it's like I wanted to come running
and like fly to this glass wall and then
then and then start to fight and
everyone is like quiet like okay and we
did it that's him and that you know in
this environment with Netflix in the way
they were it was amazing that we could
do that it could be so playful and so
was a journey I mean the movie is we
want and it's so rare to be able to do
that I mean this this movie really took
on its own shape and I can't wait for
you guys to see this on December 22nd
I'm very proud of this and I'm so proud
of the work that these guys did hey guys
hey thank you all for coming especially
you will I love you not pressure man a
big fan of all you guys
question is for David huge fan of your
work I just was wondering usually you
work in a more grounded real-world
setting and just wondering working in
the world of fantasy if you felt like it
was more challenging or liberating
adapting the social commentaries in this
film of like togetherness and living
together you know it was interesting
process because what's different about
this movie is it takes itself seriously
you know the characters in the movie
yeah it's like there's elves orcs and
all that they still have to pay their
bills they still want to be happy they
still get married they still have kids
everybody's still leading their lives
but there are the social issues there is
a stratification there is limited
mobility and and how do you deal with
that and it's a fantastic way to look at
those issues today without you know
beating people over the head with it
because sadly some people just don't
want to hear it you know they don't want
to know what's going out there in the
real world you know and this is a world
of walls and it's a world of segregation
and unfortunately amen you know we're
living it right now so what the [ __ ]
hi there my questions for will you've
done a couple sci-fi and fantasy movies
now what about genres no what about
these genres keeps bringing you back you
know when I guess I was probably 10
years old or something like that when
Star Wars came out and I got like I've
never been smashed like that in a movie
theater it was like my mind was boggled
you know and that was you know for this
generation you've seen you've already
seen magnificent things in movies and
and the special effects and what people
can do but when Star Wars came out that
it was impossible like there weren't
special effects you couldn't you
couldn't do that so it's like we were
just completely blown away and for my
entire life I've been chasing trying to
give that feeling to to fans it's like
there was nothing that I had ever
experienced in my life
that that that matched that point of
to see and I have sex a few years later
and that was pretty it was close coming
close but no Star Wars you know some
[Laughter]
all-star next question my question is
for you like kind of correlates what you
were just talking about what is the
difference between shooting like a
Netflix film versus like a big like
paramount picture or something well
there's there's no difference in the
shooting other than the process that
that you know like David was saying at
Netflix I'm sure this will end soon but
they like give you money and let you go
make the movie you want to make it's
like that that's fantastic but you know
what there is a difference between
seeing a movie in the theater and seeing
it on on not Netflix so there it is a
different thing but it's a different
thing the way it was a different thing
in the in the early days of film when
you were on stage and there were stage
plays and then you went from stage plays
to filmed entertainment so you know so
it's definitely a difference but there's
a different medium um the the thing I
can say is when when I was on the The
Fresh Prince of bel-air and yeah yeah
it's really funny because most of you
weren't born when that show actually was
off uh if you are you are you know it's
a Lucy had never seen it Lucy had never
see different I thought she had seen
every episode now I introduce it you
know but she was like oh she's from
Australia too though so but but anyway
so I was on The Fresh Prince and and you
know it was great people would see me on
the street and say well we'll hey we'll
hey will and then Independence Day came
out and that Monday after Independence
Day came out was the first day anybody
ever referred to me as mr. Smith
right so there's definitely there's
something about the step that big screen
means that does something in people's
minds that that is different there is
definitely a difference but I don't
think that it's a competitive difference
it's a it's a difference that will you
know flow and and harmonize and actually
expand the fans ability to enjoy filmed
entertainment I agree X question hey
guys my name is kion and my questions
directed for David no pun intended and
so David what's been your favorite part
about working with will whoa I mean
you're seeing it right now is he's a
good dude you know it's you know we got
a great relationship um we've learned to
really trust each other and he has you
know such a history as an actor as a
film actor he has incredible instincts
and we sort of work together where where
I'm weak he's strong
I do you strong everywhere but it's we
guide each other and we find things I
think that normally you wouldn't find if
you didn't have that relationship yeah
Trust is a big part in the actor
director relationship you know because
you know David asks you to do weird [ __ ]
sometimes yeah I've been there yeah
not want me to do what is it come on man
I got kids you know but you know you
definitely a new here you know about
that I know I was one day I'm this tells
me this really speaks for what a great
man he is one day he was off camera for
I think eight or nine hours they were on
me they turn on him like 3:00 in the
morning and he was like in such a good
mood and I was like watching this man
like one of the biggest stars we have in
the world not complaining just giving so
much love and support to me for this
like entire night and then they turned
on him did two takes and it was a wrap
that like that says everything about him
Edgar what was your experience working
with David well they bit he
first of all I'm very happy to be here
is my first comic-con earlier Ramirez
ladies gentlemen so very very excited um
David speaks flawless Spanish you speak
Spanish very well I'm not from
Connecticut as you can you know and and
he would because he does these things
you know he gets into your head and and
and and the things that he knows about
you then he used in a way that would
create the best opportunities for you to
to bring new inputs to the character and
then he would direct me the entire movie
in Spanish and then I would translate to
the crew and to the other actors where
he was telling us to do because he
wanted to create that utterly you know
like world yummy the world it was
completely out of context so those are
the kind of things that and of course we
got away with some stuff
however in California you can not that
much because a lot of people do speak
Spanish so that's not their you know but
uh but that's what some of the things
that he does yeah yeah now Lucy what is
a bright can you explain to us what a
bright is a bright is a magic user and
my character is in possession of the
ancient relic this wand that normally
brights use this wand and I can't tell
too much about it because peak is kind
of like a big bag of secrets and if I
say too much than it spills beans
um but yeah the brightest a magic user
and when warden Jacobi find the ones
that [ __ ] has that sort of when
everything unravels and we're running
away from
Nunis character in the movie if a human
were to touch a magic wand they would
just obliterate themselves you have to
be trained in in magic to actually
handle a wand and Tico's character she's
like a baby bright a baby little baby
bright she's been she's been trained and
you know we find ourselves in the
situation new Me's character is a real
full-on bright but she
us the wine and uh rowing the one inside
of my arm here's my body yeah that's
sexy like that a whole nother movie
right there okay question we can we can
hey my name is J Corwin and I wanted to
say Terry you're awesome oh and you
should have gotten fist you really
should have and Will Smith you're
awesome also thank you sorry are you for
the director did you get your thought
process from Shadowrun by any chance and
if you did not where'd you get your
whole entire thought process for the
whole entire movie with all these
different elves and orcs and everything
else it came from a fantastic script
that max landis wrote Tito has been a
fan of mine and he actually dedicated
the script to me and I never read
anything I never read scripts and my
agents like dude you got to read this
bro and I read it I'm like okay I'm in
let's do it it's this sort of genius
combination of this lore this
traditional lore and when I do so well
as a director about telling stories
about Los Angeles and law enforcement
and friendship and honor and respect and
all these things and and max really
found a vision that I hadn't seen before
in a movie so a lot of fun a lot of fun
making this film Wow alright now that's
our end of our audience questions but
will what are we about to see back now
so he I'm sorry Edgar just pointed out
and it said welcome to Comic Con please
be aware that many of the members of
your audience may be under 18 years of
age the whole wall situation yeah and
out of control yes I like to apologize
to any of the parents in the audience I
didn't read that till just now so it is
like to apologize for the wine comment
for chasing a wand think about the other
this should be printed larger I gotta
make yes I'm just seeing it now and this
is terrible this is terrible I talked
about having sex as a teenager right
this is crazy
I blamed Comic Con complain for no fault
it's right I just saw that sorry
Oh today but before we go I know we have
to go we have to go but I want to see
the trailer one more time because it was
like closed on me so I want to come out
there a little bit to be able to see it
alright so let's roll the trailer one
more time
[Applause]
you